thus by not sing and started back in
2003
now unio berlin fans make the annual
pilgrimage to their stadium not for
football but for singing your Martin's
will do exactly that we did at the start
all our own music were all Union Berlin
fans we're all amateurs on the stage and
among the crowd we come that's all part
of the charm Union have become
synonymous with Christmas in Germany not
just because their kid has the same
color as Santa who knows where this will
lead
the Christmas carols have become a
marketing tool for the club
to take gazongas songs and lights are
wonderful this might get butterflies
there is like family it is great to
experience it in my age people come from
all around the world to take part in the
singing like Madara Torres
she's from Mexico
I really like you it's a great
atmosphere and I really enjoy it it's a
different way to celebrate Christmas if
the team plays as well as their fans
sing
Unni on Berlin could well be in the
Bundesliga this time next year now
wouldn't that be a great Christmas
present